[Music]
[Music]
oh
i saw a friend today it had been a while
and we forgot each other's names
but it didn't matter cause deep inside
the feelings still remain the same
imagine going back and watching a tape
of your life
you could see yourself change and
make mistakes and grow up
you could watch yourself fall in love
watch yourself become a husband
become a father
you guys gave that to me
and that's an amazing gift
hey jim remember flonkerton when you did
office olympics
it was awesome thanks phil i still have
my medal for that
do you even have a mattress no but i
still have my medal from that
oscar oscar
[Music]
i think i'm gay
[Music]
why do you say that it's just that i'm
so emotional
am i gay and i can't no but maybe the
wreath
okay and all the faces that i know
have that same familiar glow
i think i must have known them somewhere
once before
how did you do it how did you capture
what it was really like
how we felt and how we made each other
laugh
and how we got through the day how did
you do it
also how do cameras work every day when
i came to work all i wanted to do was
leave
so why in the world does it feel so hard
to leave right now
it all seems so very arbitrary i applied
for
a job at this company because they were
hiring
i took a desk at the back because it was
empty
but no matter how you get there or where
you end
up human beings have this miraculous
gift to
make that place home
let's do this
[Music]
i just feel lucky that i got a chance to
share my crummy story with anyone out
there who
thinks that the only one to take a dump
and a paper shredder
you're not alone sister let's get a beer
sometime
[Music]
i'm happy that this was all filmed so i
can remember
everyone and what we did
i worked for a paper company all these
years and i never wrote anything down
i sold paper at this company for 12
years my job was to speak to clients
on the phone about quantities and types
of
copier paper even if i didn't love every
minute of it
everything i have i owe to this job
this stupid wonderful
boring amazing job
i thought it was weird when you picked
us
to make a documentary but
all in all i think an ordinary paper
company like dunder mifflin was a great
subject for a documentary
there's a lot of beauty in ordinary
things
isn't that kind of the point
[Music]
you